Hello everyone.
So the first question that came up,
oh,
there's something I want to say first.
First,
thank you for tuning into this Q.
And.
A.
It's always much appreciated.
Um,
it's a pleasure to do these and they
seem to be quite popular.
It's been a while since I did one,
but I've been on the road a lot and away
from my computer and so that's the
reason or the excuse take your pick.
Hopefully it's a reason.
Um,
I wanted to let you know too,
those of you who don't know,
I have worked on two programs online
that are hypothetically helpful to
people.
One is self authoring Dotcom and that
helps you write about your past and your
present and your future,
um,
to catch you up.
That's the past authoring program to
identify your faults and virtues.
That's the present authoring program.
And to make a vision and to counter
vision for your future and to make an
implementable plan.
They're writing exercises.
I produced a 20% discount for all you q
and a people today.
So if you use the discount code
august@selfauthoring.com,
then you can purchase the full set of
programs for 20% off and you have a
tooth.
I,
we have a two for one offer so you can
share that with a friend as well.
So,
and then understand myself.
Dot Com is a personality test site that
enables you to get a big five readout of
your personality with each of the big
five traits,
extroversion,
neuroticism,
agreeableness,
conscientiousness and openness broken
down into their two aspects.
So you can get a pretty comprehensive
view of your personality and that code
is also August and that's in the
description of the video in case you
forget.
So,
um,
if you're inclined,
you can use those codes and you can try
out those programs.
We know the future authoring program,
for example,
if university students do it,
especially the ones that are struggling,
it produces quite a market increase in
their propensity to stay at university
and to get better grades.
So the program seemed very,
very effective.
So if you're trying to straighten out
your life,
then I would recommend the self
authoring program.
And if you're trying to understand
yourself better or someone that you
know,
then you could try understand myself.
Dot Com.
So that's that.
Um,
the other announcement I suppose is that
I've done a tour now of about 65 cities
with tammy.
Somebody asked how she manages this.
She's exceptionally good at traveling
and very low in neuroticism.
Thank God for that because it's been a
stressful time with lots of opportunity
obviously.
And she likes to travel and so she's
very good at helping me manage this.
Um,
we're going to hit about 40 more cities,
40 or 50 more cities between now,
the end of April next year,
which is when I'm going to bring all
this touring to a close in September and
early October.
We're doing 20 cities on the eastern
seaboard of the United States.
And then in October,
near the end of October,
about 15 cities in the UK and northern
Europe.
And then in February,
Australia and New Zealand.
And then in April,
March and April,
then the rest of Europe,
um,
that's the plan anyways in perhaps
there'll be some side trips during those
times to other places.
And so you can find out about
that@jordanbpeterson.com forward slash
events.
You're more than welcome to come to the
talks.
They've been very good events in my
estimation.
Um,
I've really enjoyed them.
I can tell you I enjoy doing those talks
and I find them a lot less stressful
than talking to journalists.
The crowds are there,
the individuals in the crowds are there
to come and listen to a serious
discussion about how life might be
improved and they're very,
very positive events.
So I've been very happy to do them.
The Sam Harris Videos,
I did four talks with Sam Harris.
Those are in preparation.
We hope we'll have them out in August.
Everybody's trying to come to an
agreement about how they should be
released.
It's rather complicated affair given how
many people are involved.
But I think we're close to figuring that
out.
Um,
there'll be 10 hours of tape talks for
sessions,
two and a half hours each.
I think the talks were very,
very productive.
We'll see.
The audiences seem to,
um,
react positively to them and they were
very well attended.
We had 8,500 people in Dublin,
so,
and about 6,500 in London.
So those were very large crowds.
So that's very cool.
12 rules for life has sold about 2
million copies now.
And for those of you who are
mathematically Geek inclined,
that's 57 miles of bookshelf.
If the books are stacked,
uh,
you know,
as you would put books on a bookshelf.
So that's a lot of books and maps of
meaning.
I released the Audio version of that
June 12th,
2018 and it hit,
did it hit the New York Times bestseller
list for audio books in July and August.
So that was rather comical given that 12
rules for life was never put on the New
York Times bestseller list.
So I thought that was an ironic little
touch of fate and I'm quite pleased to
see how the audio book is doing.
If you like 12 rules for life and you're
looking for something that delves more
deeply into the same themes,
then you could try maps of meaning.
And I think the audio book,
which I read is more accessible than the
written book.
Um,
people seem to be responding to it that
way.
So I'm pretty happy about all the
positive things that are happening.
Um,
so,
okay.
How am I,
that's the first question.
well,
pretty good.
Actually.
My health seems to have stabilized
substantially.
I'm feeling pretty sharp.
Um,
I have periods of some negative mood,
although they're short and sweet,
uh,
so to speak.
But I'm seem to be sharp cognitively and
I can concentrate for long periods of
time and get lots done.
I've been able to do quite a bit of
writing in the last couple of months,
partly blog posts,
partly.
Also,
I had the privilege of being asked to
write the introduction to the 50th
anniversary version,
single volume,
abridged version of soldier Knutson's
Gulag archipelago.
And I finished that about a week and a
half ago that took me about two months
to write,
um,
about 3,500 words,
if I remember correctly.
It was a daunting task to write an
introduction to a book as tremendously
influential and um,
and important and,
and also have exceedingly high literary
quality.
So it was a daunting task to write that
introduction.
And I really wanted to get it right and
I hope I did.
I spoke by email with Solzhenitsyn's
family and they seem pleased with it and
so did the editor and I've had a couple
of editors including Gregg Hurwitz,
my novelist friend from
La who's an absolutely vicious editor
and extremely good at it.
So they were happy with the final cut,
so to speak.
So was I.
So,
um,
I seem to be sharp enough to do the work
that's necessary to do.
I've been working hard on the online
university.
I've got three people hired,
they're all very smart young guys.
Um,
and we're about a year ahead of where I
thought we'd be at this point.
We hope to have a minimally viable
product sometime in the late fall.
I'm funding that entirely at the moment,
courtesy primarily of my Patriot
support.
So thank you to all my patrion
supporters for that.
Hopefully your money's being put to good
use will probably crowdfunded in
November to see if we can set up enough
capital for the next three or four
years.
Um,
I could raise money privately.
There's lots of people are interested in
investing,
but I think that I'm going to try
crowdfunding because,
well,
because I'd like this to be a public
enterprise from the beginning,
Dan,
to have lots of people involved and
we're thinking of all sorts of ways of
getting people involved.
How am I,
other than that?
Well nonplussed and still feeling rather
surreal about my life.
I would say.
Um,
my family is in good shape.
My daughter who was very ill is doing
extremely,
extremely well.
So that's miraculous as far as I'm
concerned.
My son's getting married in September,
that's Julian and I like his fiance.
Thank God for that.
And uh,
so we're looking forward to that.
I'm going on a bit of a vacation during
August,
which is the first time I've had off for
about two years with the exception of
one week last year.
And I'm going to a family reunion and
Vancouver Island and then to
Saskatchewan to see my family.
We're going to do two talks in
Saskatchewan while I'm there,
one in Saskatoon and one in Regina.
And I have a lot of family coming to the
one in Saskatoon.
So that and then a little reunion after
that.
So that should be cool.
So,
um,
that's how I am and I'm thinking hard
about the next book.
I have a new book contract about to be a
finalized,
I think in the next week.
I'm hoping to release the next book,
which will be 12 more rules.
Um,
probably,
uh,
beyond mere order is that tentative
subtitle.
I'm hoping that I'll have it done by
spring,
early,
early spring,
perhaps January of 2020,
if not one year later,
but I'm going to try hard to hit it so
that I'm done by next September.
I'm going to write nonstop from May to
September.
And then I plan to do biblical lectures
from September through December.
So the plan is to tour from January
through May,
essentially
then to write for four months then to
lecture to prepare the biblical lectures
and so forth for four months.
And so that should be next year.
So that's an update.
Um,
hopefully that's all useful information.
I'm very pleased about all the support.
It's quite remarkable.
All this,
um,
interest in these complicated matters
and complicated discussions.
And it's so nice to see people
concentrating on psychological and
philosophical issues and leaving the
idiot politics as far behind as possible
because it's certainly a,
uh,
what would you call it,
a distraction and a dangerous one at
that.
So it's so funny talking to the
mainstream media types because
everything they talk about has to be
viewed through a political lens.
Although I continue to insist,
I did BBC hard talk,
which was aired today,
and that was a classic example of an
interviewer being entirely scripted and
trying to push everything that's
happening around me,
I suppose into a political narrative.
And it isn't political as far as I'm
concerned.
Not Everything is political despite the
insistence of people who feel that the
personal is always political.
It's like,
um,
no.
There's philosophical domain.
A theological domain in the
psychological domain though should be
kept the hell separate from politics.
All right.
What can a too agreeable young woman do
to be more disagreeable and assertive if
that isn't how she is temperamentally
inclined?
Oh,
that's a good question.
And I would say first of all,
that's a very common question that
people who go into psychotherapy ask.
I think the most common problem that
psychotherapists deal with apart from
anxiety and depression is probably
assertiveness training.
Um,
so the thing I would say is you really
need to figure out what you want.
And I would recommend doing the self
authoring program and the future
authoring program in particular because
if you want to stand up for yourself,
you have to have your goals and your
vision well laid out and well defined.
And then you have to have a strategy,
um,
that that is matched to those goals so
that you can,
so that you know what you want so that
you know when you're not getting it.
Otherwise you're left with a vague sense
of dissatisfaction and resentment.
And that's very,
very difficult thing to articulate.
And if you can't articulate it,
then you can't negotiate.
If you know what you want and you know
why,
then you can make a case for yourself.
Okay.
So let's assume now that you've laid out
a vision and a counter vision,
which the future authoring program also
helps you do.
So you know what kind of hell you want
to avoid,
that you might drift into if you were to
agreeable for the rest of your life.
And that would be a hell that consisted
mostly of people taking advantage of you
all the time and you feeling resentful
and bitter about it.
Not something I would recommend.
Um,
see,
I think that women are agreeable because
it helps them deal with infants,
but it's not a great temperamental
strategy for dealing with complex
organizations in,
in the adult world.
So I think it's a price that women pay
for.
Also being adapted to have plenty of
patients for very young children.
And then you have to overcome that to
some degree to put yourself forward
properly in more complex hierarchies of
accomplishment.
So I would say once you have your vision
established,
your vision for the future and your
counter vision,
so you're afraid of what will happen if
you don't stand up for yourself,
then you need to consult your resentment
fig.
Because if you're resentful about
something,
as far as I can tell,
there's generally only two reasons.
One is you should grow the hell up and
quit whining,
so you've got to find out first.
If you're just feeling sorry for
yourself and you can think that through,
make a pro and con case and you can talk
to somebody that you care about about
that.
I'm not assuming that that's the reason,
but that's one potential reason.
If you're not merely feeling sorry for
yourself,
then you probably have something to say
and something that you need and you need
to figure out what that is and then you
have to develop a strategy to to put
that forward.
I've seen lots of people in my personal
life and in my private practice not get
what they want because,
well,
a,
they don't specify it and B,
they don't ask for it.
And if you're negotiating safe for a
razor,
for a promotion and so forth,
you have to put yourself forward.
You need to tell your the person you're
working for,
why you should be treated with more
consideration or respect or have more
resources devoted to your more
authority.
Um,
what shifted to you?
And you have to make a case for that,
a compelling case so that they have a
reason to attend to you.
And that's not going,
they're not going to notice because most
managerial types are so overloaded with
work that they never,
when anything's going right,
they just notice the things that are
going wrong.
So you need to make a plan,
you have to have a strategy that goes
along with that plan.
You have to have articulated arguments
for why certain a certain form of
treatment is appropriate to you.
And then you have to have the courage to
put that forward.
And I guess you have to remember that
you owe yourself as much as you owe
other people.
You have to take care of yourself.
Like you take care of other people and,
and that's a moral duty and if you
practice that,
you can do it.
And a lot of that has a lot of,
that's also associated with telling the
truth.
You know,
you don't have a better friend than the
truth,
even though it can be very harsh in the
short term.
And so if you're unhappy at work because
you're being taken advantage of,
then you have to strategize yourself out
of that and you have to learn to
negotiate.
And a lot of that also means that you
have to overcome your hesitancy to
engage in conflict.
And you've got to think about it this
way.
Negotiation and conflict are somewhat
indistinguishable and it's easy moment
to moment to avoid negotiation conflict,
but you pay a terrible price for it in
the medium to long term.
It's better to face the conflict
forthrightly in the present and make
peace for the medium to long term.
And there's,
there's courage in that.
So that's the other thing I would say is
gird up your loins and,
and,
and
allow yourself to act courageously,
courageously.
And truthfully,
truth is your best bet if you're too
agreeable.
So you know,
you also might find that you have a
pretty good critical intelligence,
but that you think it's mean and so that
you keep it hidden.
Some of the smartest women I knew who
were very,
very agreeable had unbelievably good
instincts with regards to figuring out
what other people's motives were,
but they were ashamed of their
suspicions.
And really what that meant was they
ended up being ashamed of their critical
intelligence because they were so
agreeable.
So it may be that the darker part of
you,
the shadow part of you knows things that
you could know if you are willing to
admit that they were true.
And so you have to give some credence to
your,
to your darker element,
I would say.
How do you know if you were
communicating with the actual person or
a mask?
I sometimes wonder if I can ever really
know someone.
Well,
you can't ever thoroughly know someone
because people are too complicated.
You can't even really know yourself.
How do you know if you're communicating
with the actual person or a mask?
Well,
if you're communicating with an actual
person,
then you're actually having a
conversation.
You know when the conversation
transforms as a consequence of
participating in it and it tends to be
engaging and meaningful.
If what's happening is an exchange of
ideological platitudes or,
or just platitudes themselves for that
matter,
then you're probably engaging with a
mask.
So if the conversation is compelling and
meaningful and it transforms as it as it
progresses and,
and you can see that give and take that
dance,
like give and take,
then you're communicating with an actual
person.
The other thing I would say is that when
you're communicating with an actual
person rather than a mask,
the person that you're communicating
with tends to be quite interesting.
You know,
if people talk about what they know,
which means you're really communicating
with them.
If they talk about their own personal
experience instead of wandering off into
the domain of cliches and ideological
platitudes,
then people tend to be extraordinarily
interesting.
And so that's another good tactic and a
good hint that you're,
that you're where you should be when
you're conversing.
One of the rules I had when I was seeing
clients actively was that if the
conversation I was having wasn't
interesting and if my attention started
to wonder,
then we weren't discussing issues that
were sufficiently vital because if we
were discussing vital issues,
then the conversation basically flew by.
And so I think that's a good,
that's a good marker.
What new wisdom have you acquired in the
past few months that you want to share
it with us?
Well,
I've got one,
I think I thought thought up a bunch of
new things,
but this one I'm really happy with.
I figured out why.
You know,
some of you know that there's a
mythological trope that I discussed
fairly frequently about rescuing your
father from the belly of the dragon or
the belly of the beast.
It's a motif that you see when you see
it in the lion king.
Um,
you see it when Simba is being initiated
by the baboons.
Um,
I don't remember Nephi Fiki I think his
name is,
um,
after Nela humiliates him because he's
still a pathetic adolescent.
He follows the baboons.
I think it's a mandrill actually,
um,
down underground,
essentially through a long tunnel.
There's a lot of kind of scary music in
the background and he ends up
contemplating himself in a dark pool and
then his father appears in the sky.
And so that's one example of the re
construction of the mythology of
encountering your father in the abyss.
You look into the abyss and you see your
father.
And then in the Pinocchio Story,
um,
Pinocchio of course,
when he's trying to become a genuine
human being,
instead of a marionette pulled by other
people's strings or a neurotic or a,
or a liar or a jackass,
cause those are his alternate destinies.
Um,
he goes down to the darkest place he
could find the bottom of the ocean and
finds the biggest monster.
He can look at it.
And inside he finds his father and in
rescues.
And um,
and the question is,
why do you find your father when you
look into the abyss?
And I really did do,
I figured this out and it's quite
exciting to me.
All right.
It's such a brilliant image.
So we know as clinicians,
and also I would say a sensible people,
but there's good clinical documentation
of this that if you find out,
imagine someone's pursuing a goal and
some of the things they have to
accomplish or confront on the way to
that goal,
frightened them and they start to avoid
and then they get more afraid.
And of course their ability to pursue
their goal or to accomplish their goal
deteriorates because they're avoiding,
if you're a psychotherapist or even a
friend or,
or,
or a supportive loved one,
let's say,
you're going to encourage the person to
face the challenges that are making them
afraid to face them voluntarily.
And what happens as a consequence of
that is that the person usually is able
to overcome those fears and develop the
necessary skills and,
and to prevail.
And that's partly because not so much
because they get less afraid,
but because they get more skilled and
more courageous.
And so imagine that if you
bite off a little more than you can
chew,
you get stronger as a consequence.
And you do that in the gym.
For example,
when you go lift weights,
you lift weights that are a little
heavier all the time.
And as a consequence,
you develop yourself physically and you
turn into who you could be.
You turned into more than you are.
Okay?
So if you face fears a little bit at a
time,
fears and challenges,
and you do that voluntarily,
then you become more than who you are.
Okay?
Now let's recast that in architectural
language and make it into a kind of
ultimate.
So,
so if you want to become everything that
you could be,
then you look into the abyss itself,
which is the darkest place that you can
possibly contemplate.
And that would be the terror of more
mortality and insanity.
And,
and if suffering and end of malevolence,
all of those,
it would be like looking into hell,
I suppose to some degree.
And then by voluntarily doing that,
then you call upon the strongest part of
yourself to respond.
And the strongest part of yourself is
symbolized as the sleeping farther
nested inside the beast.
And so the fundamental truth when you
look into an abyss is that you don't see
the abyss.
If you look long enough,
it's like the answer to niches
conundrum.
If you look long enough into a bis and
ambitious than the abyss looks into you,
it's like,
well,
if you look long enough into an abyss
passed when the abyss looks into you,
you see who you could become in the form
of your,
of the great ancestral figures nested
inside the catastrophe of life and then
you can join them so to speak.
You can incorporate that and become
stronger and you do that partly by
taking on the challenge voluntarily and
that informs you because you learn when
you take on challenges voluntarily.
But you also do that as a consequence of
psychophysiological transformation
because when you place yourself in
challenging situations,
let's say the abyss is the archetype of
the ultimately challenging situation,
then you turn on new genes in your
nervous system and in your body that
code for new proteins and you build new
structures inside of you and none of
that's going to happen without the
demand that's placed on you by willing
to confront the full terror of life.
And so then I would say the full terror
of life is something like the reality of
suffering and death and the ever present
in the,
the ever looming presence of malevolence
in your own heart and in the heart of
other people.
So it's evil and suffering and to
confront that is really well you risk
blindness by confronting that.
That's also a very old story.
You risk damaging your vision,
but if you do it forthrightly,
then you discover who you could be as a
consequence and who you could be is the
solution to malevolence and suffering.
And so that just blew me away when I
figured that out.
It was partly a consequence of,
um,
having lengthy discussions with Sam
Harris and thinking this through more
and more been pushed to think it
through.
But I think that's an absolutely
staggering.
Um,
what would you call it?
Articulating that,
articulating that image fully for me.
I don't know if I've articulated it
fully,
but articulating it more fully really
had a profound effect on me.
I think that's,
it's such a brilliant conceptualization
that inside the darkest place is the
heroic ancestor that whose identity you
could incorporate.
Perfect.
It's perfect.
And I really believe it's true.
And what it does is it says that human
being is actually stronger than the
greatest challenge that can be set
before him or her.
And that's really something.
I also believe it's true.
It doesn't matter how,
the other thing that's so interesting
about that is that it,
it transforms pessimism into optimism.
It's like,
well,
the world is a very dark place.
It's full of suffering and it's full of
malevolence.
And it might even be so full of
suffering and malevolence that a
reasonable person could question the
justification of its being a,
as a Ivan Karamozov does in,
in the brothers Karamazov which I would
highly recommend.
By the way,
that's an absolutely great book,
dusty fce.
Um,
but the,
the truth of the matter seems to be that
if you face the pessimism full frontal,
so to speak,
um,
then you find something in you that can,
that's strong enough to take it on.
And that's really says something about,
what would you say the relationship
between human beings in divinity,
I would say,
because it takes something transcendent
of transcendent power to be able to rise
above the genuine suffering and
malevolence of life.
And I do think that we have that within
us if we don't shy away from the
challenge.
So you know,
there's in,
in the story of King Arthur and the holy
grail,
so the holy grail is one of two things.
It's a cup that either held the,
that Christ drank at the last supper or
that was used to catch his blood when he
was speared on the cross.
Either one.
But it's the,
it's the reservoir,
let's say,
of the fluid that eternally nourishes.
It's something like that.
And when you go to look for the holy
Grail,
you don't know where to look because you
don't know where the holy grail is.
And so King Arthur and his knights who
all sit at a round table because they're
essentially equals each go off to find
the holy grail.
And each of them enters the forest to
begin the quest at the place that looks
darkest to him.
And that's another example of the same
idea,
is that what you and another,
it's another example of a dictum from
Carl Young,
which he extracted from the all chemical
literature,
which was in stir curliness invented
tour,
which means roughly speaking in filth
that will be found or more to the point
what you most need will be found where
you least want to look,
but you have to look purposefully.
If it chases you,
your prey,
if you confront it,
then you're the thing that can transcend
it.
And that's a unbelievably optimistic
message because it suggests that if
you're willing to take on the burden of
being with it's suffering and
malevolence,
that you can awaken that with that which
is within you,
that will allow you to prevail.
And God only knows how deep an idea that
is.
It might be the deepest of ideas because
who knows what the limit of a human
being is so well,
that's some of the wisdom,
so to speak,
that have acquired in the last few
months.
And there's quite a bit more too.
But I,
I'm going to write all this down and
hopefully publish a bunch of it.
And my next book I figured out a bunch
about hierarchies to and how they
function.
And a whole,
I've developed a whole new way of
conceptualizing.
One of the things I was arguing with
about Sam arguing with about with Sam
Harris was the relationship between
facts and values because Sam and he has
his reasons.
We'd like to propose that we can derive
values directly from facts.
And he wants to do that because he wants
to nail the world of values to something
solid so it doesn't float in air and,
and,
and get,
let's say,
um,
what would you call it?
Hijacked by the fundamentalists or
dissolve into nihilism.
And both of those are terrible ends for
a hierarchy of value.
So he wants to nail it to something more
objective and,
and less relativistic and less,
less grounded in revealed truth that
removes it from the domain of
fundamentalism.
And so I can understand his point and
why he wants to do that.
But the problem is is that it isn't easy
to drive values from facts because
there's an infinite number of facts and
by necessity a very finite number of
values.
In fact,
most of the time when you're doing
something,
you're reducing the whole world to value
and that value is encapsulated in
whatever goal you happened to be
pursuing at the moment or whatever
you're paying attention to,
which is also a form of goal directed
pursuit.
And so I've also figured out that,
and I kind of knew this,
but I could articulate it better now,
that you look at the world of facts
through a hierarchy of values and that
hierarchy of values is instantiated in
your nervous system and simultaneously a
social construct because you pay
attention to things of value that you
and everyone else have established as
valuable through a process of social
negotiation.
And you need to pay attention to what
you think that's valuable,
that everyone else thinks is valuable
because otherwise you wouldn't have any
basis for shared attention and you
wouldn't have any basis for trade with
other people.
So that's another thing.
So that's really been helpful because,
so now I figured out that you reduce the
infinite world of facts to the finite
world of values by viewing the world of
facts through what's essentially a
dominance hierarchy of value.
And that's,
and that that exists both out in the
social world and neurologically at the
same time.
And so that's been unbelievably useful
to figure out too,
and a part of a mystery that I'd been
trying to untangle for about three
decades.
So that's extremely helpful.
And I've also spent some more time
thinking about the proper place of the
right and the left wing.
So the right wing basically stands for
the,
um,
what would you call the,
the right wing serves as an advocate for
hierarchy.
And the left wing serves as a critic of
hierarchy and the rights says,
well,
we need hierarchies there often
hierarchies of competence,
they're necessary to organize people and
society and they're necessary to get
things done,
all of which is true.
And the left says yes,
but hierarchies dispossessed and you
have to pay attention to the widows and
the orphans,
which is also true.
And so then the political discussion is
about how to ensure that hierarchies are
maintained and are functional,
but also have sufficient mercy within
them to take care of the people who for
one reason or another are struggling to
find their place even in a hierarchy of
competence.
And then the necessity for free speech
emerges out of that because the left and
the right have to communicate.
So that,
okay,
the proper balance between the,
the,
the current structure of the hierarchy
and it's transformation and mercy can be
established on an ongoing basis.
So anyways,
there are three things that I've really
learned over the last few months.
There's a bunch more,
but those will do for now.
Um,
if too much masculine masculinity is
tyranny,
but the right amount is order and too
much feminine is chaos,
what's the word for the right amount of
femininity?
That's a really good question.
I read that a bit earlier and I couldn't
come up with something immediate.
But the only thing I can think of is
that often femininity has been
characterized as wisdom.
And maybe that's so,
so the,
the wisdom that God in the Judeo
Christian tradition that God consults is
feminine.
That's an old tradition.
And maybe that's because order needs to
be leaving with the right amount of
chaos in order for wisdom to emerge the
order,
it can be blinded and tyrannical and
dead.
And so it's,
it's the mixture of the right amount of
chaos that turns that order into wisdom.
And then that wisdom is often persona
fired,
his feminine.
Now that doesn't exactly answer your
question because it doesn't make the
right balance.
You still don't have tyranny order.
Okay.
You still don't have order tyranny,
chaos.
You're still missing the proper word
there.
Um,
I don't,
it's a,
it's a good question.
And,
and the wisdom ideas,
the best I can make of it for now,
is it better to marry someone with your
temperament or a contracting
complimentary temperament?
Well,
there is evidence on this and basically
you don't want to marry someone with
whom you're two mismatched.
Now,
the only possible exception to that is
neuroticism.
Neuroticism is a good predictor of
marital trouble and it's a good
predictor of trouble,
period.
Or perhaps sensitivity to trouble,
which is in some sense the same thing.
It's very,
and I don't know of any research
specifically pertaining to this.
Um,
no,
I know that people who are high in
neuroticism are more likely to miss work
and to visit the doctor and to um,
and,
and to be unhappy in their marriages and
so forth.
And that may also account for why 75% of
divorces are initiated by women.
Um,
and I think women are more sensitive to
negative emotion,
partly because they have to take care of
infants and need to be more sensitive to
threat.
And perhaps because sexuality is more
dangerous to women and perhaps because
women are physically smaller and all of
this seems to kick in at puberty
anyways.
It isn't obvious to me that you want to
match someone with regards to
neuroticism.
If you're high in neuroticism,
I think if you're high in neuroticism,
you need to find someone who's low in
neuroticism,
um,
because then you have someone around to
calm you down.
Now apart from that,
the research literature does indicate
match is better and you can see why it's
hard for extroverts and introverts to
get along if they're,
especially if they're extreme extroverts
and extreme introverts because an
extreme extrovert always wants to be
with other people and in groups and an
extreme introvert hardly ever wants that
and that's a very,
very difficult thing to negotiate.
And then with conscientiousness,
same thing.
If you're really high in orderliness,
it's very hard to be married to someone
who very low and ordered in this.
You're going to end up doing all the
cleaning for example,
that will drive you crazy and if you're
high and industriousness,
same thing,
healthy are super high and
industriousness and orderliness.
You might want someone who's maybe
moderate in both to kind of temper you a
bit because one of the problems with
being too high in conscientiousness is
that you can't stop working and you
should probably stop working from time
to time.
Agreeableness,
same thing,
hard for an agreeable and disagreeable
person to get along.
You know,
the agreeable person will always be
the disagreeable person
who won't shy away from conflict is
likely to dominate the agreeable person
quite badly.
So that's a tough bridge to two.
That's a tough chasm to bridge as well.
So you look for temperamental
similarity.
I'm at now it's complicated because like
if you're really,
really low and industriousness and you
marry someone else who's really low and
industriousness,
well that's going to be trouble for both
of you because there isn't going to be
anyone around who's going to do the
work.
So,
um,
you might understand each other better,
but as a longterm strategy it's not a
very good one.
So
it seems like your message is primarily
positive masculine,
whereas the positive feminine is not
elaborated with near the same
resolution.
What do you think?
Um,
I don't really think that's true.
I,
I think that might be somewhat true of
12 rules for life,
although I'm not convinced of that.
That message and 12 rules for life is to
find a balance between order and chaos.
And there's plenty of discussion in
there about the danger of an excess of
both.
Certainly maps of meaning is,
um,
elaborated out more with regards to the
positive masculine or with regards to
maps of meaning is elaborated out more
completely than 12 rules with regards to
the positive role of the masculine and
the feminine.
Um,
I think it's complicated in part because
the feminine classically speaking is
associated with smaller scale intimate
familial groupings.
And so
in a world that's obsessed with
adaptation to large scale social
systems,
it's harder to make a case for the role
of the feminine.
We don't understand the role of the
feminine in large scale social
structures.
So,
and you know,
we don't have a cultural myth apart from
beauty and the beast,
let's say,
that describes the role of an
independent female operating in the
fundamentally masculine social world.
And we don't even know what something
like that would look like.
And there aren't guiding stories to some
degree because women haven't been able
to do that except in the last hundred
years.
So I don't know what,
what the positive feminine on a large
scale would look like.
And we don't have guiding stories for
that.
This is partly to underlined the
absolutely radical nature of the birth
control pill.
And and not only that,
but the provision of,
of,
of technological devices that aid women
in dealing practically with their weekly
or their monthly menstrual cycle,
which was also a huge impediment to
women in terms of interacting in the,
let's say the patriarchal world.
So now women can take their place in the
broader cultural world and we don't know
what the model for that is.
So you know,
you might say,
well they should adopt the heroin
masculine perspective and certainly to
some degree that's true,
but that's not a particularly fruitful
archetype when it comes to having a
family and having a family is actually
extraordinarily important and it's
certainly the thing that dominates the
thoughts of the majority of women as
they approached their thirties all
cultural noise to the contrary.
So it's something we're still puzzling
out and I suppose I'm still puzzling it
out too.
I mean with my daughter,
I tried to encourage her to be as sharp
and is intelligent and critically minded
and ambitious as she could be,
but also let her to let her know that
if,
and she,
she,
she was always interested in having
kids.
Um,
but to also let her know that having a
family as an extremely important thing,
um,
how to balance that.
Well that is the modern conundrum isn't
it?
We want to figure out how to maximize
our access to the talents of women but
also to set up a situation where it's
possible for talented women and women of
all talents let's say as well,
but talented women who have options in
the workplace to also have a family and
this is a tremendously complex problem
and it isn't clear how it's going to be
solved.
You know,
there is data showing,
you know,
you say,
well men should pick up more of the
feminine role and I suppose that's
possible.
But there is good data showing for
example,
that if you show women pictures of men
engaged in classically masculine,
you know,
fixing a roof for fixing the plumbing or
so forth,
um,
or in feminine endeavors doing the
dishes and,
and,
and vacuuming that the women raped the
man who are doing the female tasks as
well as less sexually attractive.
And so it's not all on the men with
regards to the utility of them picking
up a more feminine role,
you know,
and it isn't necessarily the case that
women will find men who are more
domestic,
also maximumly sexually attractive.
Those things don't necessarily go
together.
So this is very,
very complicated.
So
I'm quite shy and when asked questions
in public,
I find it hard to articulate a good
answer,
but we'll come up with a strong response
hours or days later.
Any advice?
Yeah,
I have some advice.
One is that,
um,
well you're probably introverted a so
you're not as verbally fluent as an
extrovert would be a not quite as fast
on the draw verbally,
but you know,
that means you need some more time to
contemplate and maybe you're high in
negative emotion too.
Um,
because shyness can be a combination of
introversion and high negative emotion.
It can be one or the other,
but,
but technically shy is introverted.
Um,
anyways,
what I would certainly recommend for you
is that if you're faced with a
complicated question,
especially one that has to do with an
important decision in your life,
that you say,
I need to sleep on it or I need a couple
of days and not to answer,
um,
on the draw.
I mean,
I think that's true even for extroverts.
I think if you're at called upon to
offer your opinion about something
complex,
then it's perfectly reasonable to say,
look,
that's a really hard question.
I'm not going to give you a casual
answer.
I need to think about it for a couple of
days.
So the advice would be because you find
it hard to articulate a good answer,
don't allow yourself to be rushed.
And the second is to understand that
this is part of your temperament there.
There isn't anything wrong with it.
It's just,
it's,
it's how you're wired.
So
what causes a person to hoard?
Is it due to low conscientiousness?
What is generally the best course of
treatment?
Um,
it's usually a consequence of relatively
high in neuroticism.
Um,
and it's tangled in with disgust,
sensitivity as well.
People who hoard have a hard time,
they feel guilty if they throw things
away because the thing's still have some
residual utility.
The best course of treatment is well
behavioral therapies probably the best
course of treatment.
Um,
and to plan what needs to be thrown away
and to work with a person that can help
you make the hard decisions that,
that need to be made.
If you're hoarding
all that,
all that hoarded material is,
and it's decisions that have been put
off.
So a lot of that is high neuroticism.
I,
some of that can be a consequence of low
conscientiousness as well.
So the best course of treatment is to
find someone to help you plan how to
approach the,
the horde.
Very complicated.
So all right.
Which hogwarts house would you be in?
Well,
I think I'd have the same issue as Harry
Potter when the hat was first put on,
it would think that I might make a
perfectly good dennis in of slitherin.
So,
um,
although that probably wouldn't be where
I would end up.
So
what is your take on an astrological
basis for significant dates in religious
stories?
Example,
Christian religion is a parody on the
worship of the sun.
Well,
it's certainly not a parody.
Um,
religion,
religious systems as they expand tend to
incorporate everything that's quasi
religious in the culture.
And there's certainly no shortage of
solar symbolism in Christianity.
I mean,
it's not fluke that that Christ is the
son and there are 12 disciples just like
there are 12 astrological houses and
it's not fluke that,
um,
the birth of Christ takes place
essentially at the,
at the same time as,
as,
as the shortest day of the year and the
rebirth of the sun.
All of these things line up.
Now,
whether that synchronicity or whether
it's the attempt by the collective
imagination of human beings to align
everything under a single truth,
that's a very difficult thing to say.
Or maybe there's a single truth at work.
But the idea that Christian religion is
a parody on the worship of the sun is
not,
is definitely not the case.
It's more like it's incorporated
elements of the worship of the sun over
thousands and thousands of years.
And that's a very complicated issue.
If you're interested in that,
you could read I on Ai,
o n it's booked by Carl Young,
which is like the most terrifying book
I've ever read.
And so you could,
there's a deeper analysis of the
relationship between astrological
speculation,
um,
and,
and the emergence of complex religious
stories.
So
my brother 29 to sick at home with
burnout.
He's a perfectionist,
has anxiety,
has trouble dealing with stress.
How can I help them become stronger?
Well,
you could encourage him to go talk to a
therapist.
You could tell him to go find broadly,
make an appointment with three of them.
Go talk to each one for an hour and if
he likes one of them and he finds one
who listens,
then he can go back a couple more times.
But it isn't going to hurt him to go
once at least to go talk.
Um,
it's also possible that he needs someone
to talk to them about medication.
You know,
antidepressants,
if he's written real trouble.
Antidepressants are often very helpful
to people,
not always,
but often.
And so that is a lot better.
Taking an antidepressant beats the hell
out of being sick at home with burnout
and it's attended dangers,
cognitive dangers,
dangers of stress induced illness,
dangers of suicidal ideation,
all that sort of thing.
Um,
I would also recommend that he tried the
self authoring program.
If he's at home,
he could write about his past,
he could write about his presence,
he could write about his future.
He can do a bad job,
he can do it over days.
I think that,
I mean we have evidence that the program
is extremely helpful to people and
there's evidence from other researchers
that such programs really help.
So that would,
that would be something that he could
do.
Well,
he's sitting at home and it's not going
to hurt him.
I'm going over some of the more complex
material might make them feel slightly
worse in the short term,
but the long term payoff is very,
very high.
So,
um,
that's what I would recommend.
Encourage him to go talk to somebody he
knew and he needs to make the planning
needs to come to terms with what's
happened to him.
And He needs to make a plan and he might
need to talk to somebody for a long time
to figure out what the hell's going on.
You know?
And we also don't want to rule out,
neither does he.
The possibility that there's something
physical wrong,
you know,
because there's increasing evidence that
the depressive disorders and that would
include anxiety,
are consequence of,
of such conditions as,
as generalized inflammation.
And that's really worth looking into.
So I think a lot of the things that we
think are psychological have a more
pronounced physical basis.
So,
yeah.
How do you dress so well,
any tips?
Well,
you know,
thank you.
Um,
I started buying
nice clothes,
let's say this year.
Really.
I had some decent suits before that.
Um,
I did some research online to find out
who good suit manufacturers where you
can look that up.
But in before this tour,
I went and talked to a good tailor,
a expensive place.
I felt terrible spending so much money
on clothing.
Um,
but I felt that if I was going to go
talk to,
it's been 200,000 people that I was
going to do it right and,
and I was going to invest in some decent
clothes.
And even though it,
it hurt my,
um,
cheap northern Alberta soul to do it,
it was definitely worth it.
So go talk to someone who knows what
they're doing.
Go talk to an actual Taylor and,
and,
and you can do some research online.
There's lots of resources online that
are devoted towards devoted to helping
men figure out how to dress.
Three piece suits look pretty good.
I,
I've got them tailored and fitted,
so they're not bespoke suits,
they're off the rack,
but they've been tailored and that makes
a big difference.
Uh,
all this subtle things that Taylor's do,
they tuck it in around the waist,
they cut it to your body.
All of those things help.
It's really good to have a good pair of
shoes.
Couple of Nice ties.
I learned how to tie off full Windsor
Knot recently and that actually helps.
So you don't want your tire to look too
skinny.
Um,
lots of people have been dressing up to
come to my talk,
so it's nice to see a lot of young men
come well dressed often in three piece
suits,
but not always.
And it's really good to see them dressed
like grown ups.
I think that's a real plus.
Um,
I had a rule that I didn't write in 12
rules,
which was dressed like the person you
want to be.
That's,
I kind of took that from Carl from,
from nature because Nisha said every
great man is an actor of his own ideal.
So very nice.
Eight for Islam.
And basically what it meant was that
sometimes you have to act out what you
want to be before you become it.
You have to pretend,
and it's not a lie,
it's,
it's really a pretense.
Like children pretend to be a father
before they grow up and become a
farther,
it's a form of practice.
And so tip one might be,
I figured out who you want to be.
Tip Two might be well then dressed like
that person.
That's a good start.
And because I think if you want to
become who you want to be,
then no detail is too small to overlook.
And certainly it isn't exactly that.
People judge you by their clothes,
buy your clothes,
although they do to some degree.
It's that
if whatever you can have going for you,
you might as well have going for you.
That's how it looks to me.
And certainly my experience has been
that the response to my improved
wardrobe has indicated that the
investment was clearly worth it,
um,
indisputably and clearly worth it.
And it's nice to be dressed sharply to
go in front of an audience.
It's a sign of respect to the audience.
There's other ways of showing respect to
an audience,
but that's certainly one.
And so it's been extraordinarily
worthwhile.
I would say if you're going for a job
interview,
if you're at any critical point in your
life,
then you should dress the part because
you want to do everything.
You can tip the scales in.
Not In your favor exactly,
but in favor of having the right thing
happen.
So
you have written an article on how to
write.
Can you do the same on how to speak?
Well,
I suppose I could,
I could tell you a little bit about it.
Um,
if you're going to speak about
something,
you need to know a lot about it.
You need to know three or four times as
much as you're going to speak about at
minimum.
So first of all,
you have to do your background research.
You have to have multiple stories at
hand that you can use to illustrate your
point.
And you have to have a point,
you have to organize what you're talking
about around a problem.
So before I go on stage to speak on my
tour,
I always sit for half an hour,
some of which involves usually about
five minutes of anxiety.
And I think,
okay,
there's a problem.
I'm trying to address tonight a central
problem or a theme,
what is,
it might be courage.
It might be responsibility,
it might be meaning.
Um,
I think that serves as an organizing
principle.
So that would be the point.
And then basically I organize say a
dozen stories around that and I can kind
of arrange them in it as a journey.
And it's a journey that circles the main
point.
And so I'm trying to explore it to say
what I think about courage,
let's say,
but to take what I'm thinking farther
than I've taken it already.
And so then I can plot out,
you know,
little five minute stories that I have
that are associated with courage.
And then I can talk to the audience and
I would say,
talk about what you know,
use your personal experience because
that's,
that's something that you're actually a
master of.
You can bring in other material,
but it has to be tied to the real world
through your own experience.
Otherwise it's not real.
It's also very good to speak directly to
the audience,
to the individuals in the audience.
Cause I'm always looking at a single
person,
one after another and focusing on them
and talking to them.
Just like you'd have a conversation with
someone.
And that way I can see if they're
following along and I'm always listening
to the audience.
What I really like to hear from the
audience is no noise at all.
Silence because of the audience,
especially,
you know,
if it's a couple of hundred or a couple
of thousand people,
if the audience is dead silent,
then I know that I'm on the right track.
And so
the other thing I would say is you're
telling stories.
So every fact that you relate or every
set of facts has to be tied to a story.
There has to be a meaningful output,
which is something like why is it
important to your life that you know
this fact?
How is it related to how you're going to
conduct yourself moving forward?
Or how are you going to see the world?
So that's kind of the essence of
meaning.
How does this fact change the way you
perceive the world or act in the world?
That's the meaning of the fact.
And facts without meaning are dull.
So you need to know that.
You need to tell the truth,
that's for sure.
Okay.
And,
and,
and I mean for me,
my talks are really,
they're an attempt to explore a set of
ideas in the most truthful way that I
can manage.
And that's also an adventure because
letting yourself speak freely about a
topic,
you don't always know where it's going
to go.
And so,
but that also hooks in the audience
because they're not,
they're along for the ride,
right?
And there's a risk.
Risk is you might forget where you are,
you might lose the thread.
You might say something you regret,
you might get confused.
And it's this,
the talk should be a process of
exploration,
like a journey that you're taking the
audience along on.
It's the same when you're reading a
novel,
like a great novel isn't exactly plotted
out from beginning to end to begin with.
The author is taking himself or herself
and you on an intellectual adventure
through the,
through the character development and
the characters have to be allowed to
live and to express themselves.
And the novel needs to unfold.
It's like a color coy between the
conscious mind and the unconscious
source of inspiration.
And the novel is actually a journey
through a character,
a logical landscape.
And the author's shouldn't know where he
or she is going to end up at the
beginning.
Same with an artist and who's,
who's writing a song or,
or,
or a piece of music or a piece of visual
art.
There has to be play and exploration
along the way.
And so you also don't want to deliver an
overprepared talk in my estimation,
or at least that's not how I do it.
You want to have a theme,
you want to have a body of knowledge
from which you can draw on.
And then you want to be actively
exploring the idea in front of the
audience.
And that's very gripping for everyone,
including you.
And so,
and you should learn something from the
talk.
It's an opportunity to think on your
feet.
And anyways,
that's my style of lecturing.
Um,
it's,
it's a trapeze act without a safety net,
I would say.
And that's part of what makes it
gripping is that there's a high
probability of failure.
And I would say with any performance
that's going to be
gripping,
that on the edge of the seat gripping,
there has to be a high probability of
failure.
And that's why I don't speak with notes.
Um,
if you speak with notes,
which you might have to,
if you're a beginning speaker,
then you can not fail because you can
always read the notes.
And so there's a,
there's a nap,
you'll fall in the net,
but you won't die,
but you'll never do anything
spectacular.
So that's the thing is if you're going
to do something spectacular,
you have to take the risk.
And if you're going to take the risk,
you have to think on your feet.
And then you also have to have something
to think about.
You have to be,
have been working on this material.
You know,
I've been working on this stuff I talk
about for 30 years,
for tens of thousands of hours.
And so I have that reservoir of
knowledge.
I suppose that,
you know,
whenever I read something new,
I'm slotting it into the node structure
that I use to generate my talks and I'm
reading all the time and lots of the
things I read,
I forget.
They're not relevant to my central
mission,
whatever that happens to be.
It looks like some,
it looks something like the delineation
of the relationship between
responsibility and meaning and,
and maybe responsibility meaning and
perception.
It's something like that.
And so I have a central concern or
deeper than that in some sense.
Um,
my central concern was how do ensure
personally that if I was tempted in a
situation like the situations that arose
in the Soviet Union and Nazi Germany,
that I wouldn't fall prey to those
totalitarian systems and act in the
reprehensible manner that so many people
act at the end.
That's really been a driving concern of
mine.
And,
and that's bleeds over into the
relationship between meaning and
responsibility and perception.
So there's a core set of problems that
I'm working on in every talk is an
attempt to further develop those.
So you also have to have a problem.
You know,
you think,
well you don't want to have a problem.
It's like,
yeah,
you do,
you want to,
you've got problems anyways.
If you're alive,
you've got problems.
Pick one of them.
It can be your problem and that can be
the problem.
You try to address whatever that happens
to be.
And then you have something to talk
about.
How am I going to address this problem?
How can this problem be addressed?
So you need to have a problem too.
If you're going to talk just like you
need to have a problem if you're going
to write because the writing is an
attempt to solve the problem.
And so is there talking.
If you're not trying to solve a problem,
what the hell are you doing talking?
Why should anyone care?
It's got to be a real problem to like,
uh,
you know,
a nail biter of a problem,
a dragon have a problem.
And if it's a problem that everyone else
shares so much,
the better.
So,
and then you grapple with it.
So
thoughts on the eastern idea of moving
away from excessive thinking into the
awareness beyond thinking,
removing it from the driver's seat to be
used more as a tool?
Yeah,
well I thought a lot about this in
relationship to
a couple of ancient ideas.
The one Mesopotamia and idea,
a characterization of Marduk who was the
highest Mesopotamian Daddy.
All right.
It was Marta who carved up the goddess
of chaos,
Tie Amat into pieces and made the world
out of her pieces.
So Martech is the force that confronts
chaos and builds habitable order,
like the logos in genesis.
And one of Martex attributes was that he
had eyes all the way around his head and
that he could speak magic words,
those two attributes,
but it's the eyes they that are of most
crucial importance with regard to this
question.
Then there's horus,
the Egyptian God who's the famous I and
horses,
really a,
Oh,
what a day of vacation of attention I
would say.
And there's a difference between
attention and thinking.
Like let,
let me give you an example.
So thinking to be instrumental mostly so
if your thing,
but people also often say to me,
well what's your,
what's your strategy when you go into an
interview?
And the answer is,
well,
I don't have a strategy when I go into
an interview because I'm there to have a
conversation and I'm not sure where the
conversation will go and I'm willing to
let it go wherever it goes.
I'm not there to sell books,
although I'm perfectly happy if more
books sell because,
well,
because obviously I wrote a book and I
want people to read it and there's a
whole enterprise behind it.
And so it's also my responsibility to do
the marketing properly.
But I'm not going to do these interviews
to sell books or to promote myself or,
or I don't have a strategic goal in mind
except that I'm going to have a
conversation and I'm going to say what I
think and,
and,
and take the consequences because I
assumed that if I say something and I
believe it's true,
then the consequences are as positive as
they can be regardless of how they look
at the time.
And that's an issue of faith because I
believe that the habitable order is
generated by spoken truth.
I believe that.
I think that's the truest,
that's the truest thing.
I know.
And so,
and so I go into the interview and I did
this in my clinical practice and I try
to do this when I'm talking to people
too,
is that I'm not thinking about where the
conversation is going or what point I
want to make or what I want the outcome
to be.
Any of that.
I just let that go.
You know,
it's within this broader framework of
assuming that the truth is the most
effective means of progressing and then
I pay attention.
And what happens when you pay attention
is that while you're watching a person,
this is a great treatment for social
anxiety,
by the way,
because if you're socially anxious,
you tend not to pay attention to the
person.
Pay attention to who you're talking to.
Watch them like a hawk,
like not paranoid or anything like that,
and not too intently because you make
them uncomfortable but intently.
Pay attention to what they're saying to
how they look to their facial gestures,
all of that look at their face and watch
and listen and try to understand what
they're saying.
And what you'll see is that,
well questions pop into your mind.
It's like,
well,
I didn't understand what you said.
Can you clarify that?
And it sounds like you mean this is this
what you mean?
But not in a,
I'll put you on the spot because I think
you're wrong sort of way,
but in a clarification sort of way and
all of that attention.
And so what I'm doing clinical work with
people,
and this is the reason I quit by the way
about a year ago is because I was
starting to get distracted.
I had a rule which was,
you have an hour with me and I do
nothing but pay attention to you.
I'm not thinking about what I wanted to
accomplish.
I'm not thinking about the problems in
my life.
I'm not distracted.
And I listened to you and I ask
questions when I don't understand.
And if a thought,
oh,
occurs to me while I'm paying attention
to you,
then I'll tell you what it is you see.
And that's,
that's using awareness primarily
thinking secondarily like I don't think,
well here's what I,
how I want to cure this person and I'm
going to maneuver them into certain
responses by using these communicative
tools.
I think I'm going to pay attention to
this person.
We're going to discuss where we're going
and why I'm going to listen to what they
say.
And then when they're talking things are
going to occur within me.
I'm going to see images and thoughts are
going to emerge from the background and
then I'll share them.
Not always because I usually have more
thoughts than can be shared.
But if a thought comes up and it seems
like an interesting reaction to what the
person just said,
then I'll just tell them and sort of
without commitment to it.
And it's usually okay,
you just said this and so this question
emerged so we need to straighten that
out cause I'm,
I'm confused.
Or You said this and I had this image or
you said this and this thought came to
mind and it seems to be this is this.
So that's one person's reaction to the
way that you're conducting yourself at
the moment.
So,
okay,
thinking is instrumental.
I outline this in,
I think it's rule seven,
do what is meaningful,
not what is expedient.
If you do what's expedient,
you have a short term conscious goal in
mind and you try to bend everything
towards that end.
But if you're pursuing what's
meaningful,
then you just pay attention to what's
going on and you react with truth.
And I think that's,
that's a much better way of living as
far as I'm concerned.
It's,
it's a much more powerful way of living.
It means you have to confront things
right then in there,
which is I suppose why so many of my
interviews have been,
in some sense contra confrontational
because people will impose in,
uh,
thinking agenda on the flow of the
conversation.
This is especially true in the
mainstream media happened again recently
with bbcs hard talk that they impose an
agenda on the conversation.
And then that just doesn't work out very
well because
I'm paying attention and I will object
to the agenda.
Not because I haven't different agenda
except for what I said,
which is that I want to say what I think
I want to say as truthfully as I can.
What I actually am thinking in this more
abstracted and detached sense and see
what happens.
So it's,
it's a hard thing to clarify because you
might say,
well Dr. Peterson,
you just said you want to say what
you're thinking,
but it's not exactly the same thing.
It's not like I'm thinking
strategically,
I'm listening.
Thoughts emerge and I say them.
I'm not trying to,
I'm not putting a spin on things.
I'm not trying to manipulate the
conversation any particular way.
And again,
the reason for that is because I decided
a long time ago,
probably 30 years that there was no more
effective way of dealing with a complex
situation than to try to say what you
believe to be true and know how to
manipulate it.
No,
none of that.
It's just doesn't cause that's all,
those are all lies as far as I'm
concerned,
that kind of manipulation and spin.
So
if he was invited to the largest
possible number of games is also the
person that goes out to conquer the
unknown.
Could this lie and reciprocal altruism?
That's a really good question.
I would say it almost certainly does.
You certainly see the reciprocal
altruism in being invited to the largest
possible number of games.
So a little background here,
it's like,
well,
what's a winner?
Or a winner is someone who wins a game.
It's like no.
A winner is someone who gets invited to
play the largest possible number of
games.
And that means that you have to be a
good sport.
And so the good sport is the winner in
the broader game in the metagame.
Now I put forward the proposition that
the winner of the Meta game is also the
person that goes out to conquer the
unknown.
Now let's see if we can take that apart
a little bit.
Well,
one of the,
one of the attributes of being a good
sport,
let's say,
is that you're trying to extend your
skill during the game and so you are
confronting the unknown in the game
because you're trying to get better at
playing the game.
And then you're also doing that in a way
that's of benefit to the team.
And so then you can imagine that being a
team leader in,
in the metagame,
which is the game of extending your
skill across the,
across the broadest possible set of
games is analogous to leading a team
into the unknown.
So if you're going to go confront the
unknown,
you're probably not going to do it
alone,
although you could.
And to some degree you have to be alone,
but you're generally going to do it in a
cooperative and competitive way.
I mean that's why stories like the Lord
of the rings and the Hobbit for example,
and even Harry Potter for that matter,
none of those people are alone.
They,
they lead or are part of a broader
social group and they're important and
they're team players within that group.
So the team player element seems to be
something that's common to conquering
the unknown and to reciprocal altruism
and,
and to being invited to play the largest
number of games.
And the question then is what makes an
effective leader and an effective leader
is someone who is able to synthesize the
group and to lead it forward towards the
goal.
Yeah,
that's it.
And you know,
when a game,
obviously the good player is leading the
team forward to the goal.
And it's the same in a quest.
The good player is the leader who's
leading the team towards the goal.
So there's a,
there's a deep analogy there and
it's not just reciprocal altruism.
I don't think that's quite the right
terminology though,
because there's an element of pragmatic
competence that goes along with it to
you.
You are,
you can't merely be willing to engage in
reciprocal altruism,
to be a good player
or to conquer the unknown.
You also have to have skill and
discipline.
So I would say reciprocal altruism is
necessary but not sufficient
precondition,
right?
Talent,
scalability,
all of those things,
our creativity,
all of those things are also important.
So
that's a bit of an answer to that,
but it's very,
very good question.
So please confirm.
If you're a Harry Potter patroness
patronus would in fact be a frog?
We need answers,
doctor.
Well,
you'd certainly think that wouldn't you
frog?
Well,
I think that's obvious.
It's gotta be a frog or maybe a lobster.
I wouldn't have,
I wouldn't have guessed that it would be
a frog,
but that certainly seems to be how
things have developed.
And I suppose,
you know,
a frog is in home at home,
on dry land and in the water
and
that makes the frog a kind of psychopomp
and I've strived to be at home in the
air and in the water and to bring up the
gold ball from the bottom of the lake.
Like the frog.
Prince.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely frog.
Okay,
so you've got your answer.
MMM.
Well,
I've got my answer too.
I guess
on completing,
understand myself.com I scored
exceptionally low,
zero and conscientiousness,
industriousness and orderliness.
What can I do for motivation?
Well,
Dean,
the first question is how old are you?
And,
uh,
you're going to have an easier life if
you're still young.
Because if you're older and you have
that score,
then that's going to be rough.
Um,
perhaps you're high in openness,
in which case you're going to derive
your motivation from engaging in
creative endeavors.
Perhaps you're high in agreeableness,
which means that you might find meaning
and caring for other people,
perhaps extroversion,
which means you're going to find
engagement in being with other people.
Um,
so,
so those are potential sources of
motivation.
You may have to look elsewhere then
duty,
let's say.
And it chievemeet ambition for your
primary sources of motivation.
One thing I would caution you though is
that you likely need to make friends
with the scheduler.
Like Google,
try to design days you want to have and
to learn to structure your time because
okay,
even if you're high in openness,
which makes you creative,
it's,
you're going to have a hell of a time
sticking to things.
And so maybe you need to partner with
someone who's I in conscientiousness.
Um,
but I would really recommend trying to
discipline yourself.
You use,
uh,
use Google calendar to design the days
you want to have and learn to schedule
and regulate your time use because zero
is very low and my suspicions are you'll
pay quite a high price for that.
So
what do you think about Ellis Miller and
her thesis that most psychological
diseases and the parent behavior as the
result of some kind of childhood trauma?
Some are,
but some forms of childhood trauma or
also a consequence of psychological
diseases and apparent behavior.
So this is very,
very complicated.
Um,
I'm more on the existentialist front
with regards to these sorts of theory.
So Ellis Miller's thesis is basically
Freudian Freud's thesis.
Um,
Freud,
uh,
certainly posited that many forms of
psychological distress where a
consequence of childhood trauma of
various sorts.
Um,
I think the existentialist take on that
is more accurate,
which is that life in and of itself is
sufficiently harsh and full of betrayal
and other forms of malevolence to cause
any number of psychological diseases and
produce any amount of a barren behavior.
So I don't think it has to be,
it's not as if we all had childhoods
without trauma that we would have grown
up to be perfect adults.
Um,
it's,
that's also a disguised form of Rousseau
Indian philosophy and the Russo's
philosophy is people are basically good,
but culture makes them evil and that's
not true.
People are basically good and evil and
culture,
um,
fortifies the possibility of both add
strength to the possibility of both.
So,
um,
I don't,
I th I think that people are sometimes
damaged in childhood in ways that need
to be addressed in adulthood,
but that there are plenty,
plenty of other reasons for
psychological and physical disorder.
Genetic causes,
uh,
causes related to all sorts of physical
diseases.
No,
it's way too simple.
It's way too simple.
A,
um,
a hypothesis and it's caused an awful
lot of trouble because a lot of simple
minded therapists always assumed that if
someone is having psychological problems
in adulthood,
it must be because they had childhood
trauma and everybody has an unhappy
childhood to some degree.
So you can always find something.
And often the childhood trauma that
they're looking for house to be sexual.
And so they dig and dig until they find
or invent often invent something that
you know,
allows a single causal attribution and
it's just life just isn't that simple
man.
There's lots of reasons to be ill,
way more reasons to be old and to be
healthy.
So
what if the truth could unravel your
entire life?
Yeah.
Well first of all it would and second,
yeah,
I know what you mean.
You mean what if I suppose that a
cardinal case there would be that you
did something really terrible and that
if that was revealed it would be a
catastrophic situation.
It's like without knowing the details of
that,
I can't provide a generic answer.
You know,
I think that there are some sins that
are so egregious that you don't get to
confess to them.
You know?
Like if you've done something terrible,
and I'm not recommending this,
it's just an example.
If you've done something terrible and
you know that if you revealed and it
would blow the lives of many people
around you apart,
it isn't obvious to me that you have any
moral justification for confessing just
to free your miserable soul.
So what if the truth could unravel your
entire life?
Or maybe you need to go to Catholic
confession and let someone know exactly
what happened.
So you're clear about it then.
Then maybe what you need to do is to
swear to whatever God you worship that
you're going to try to walk the straight
and narrow from here on in.
And that'll be sufficient to atone for
whatever terrible thing that you did.
And that's a,
that's a form of prayer.
And it sounds like one that you
desperately need,
at least in principle.
No.
So
without knowing the details,
that's about the best I can do.
I think what put you over with so many
of us was the constructive message of
how to be a good man.
Well,
a good person I would say.
Do you think that's where the media want
you to go?
I don't know.
Generally not day.
I mentioned this earlier is that the
media as it disintegrates and it
certainly is disintegrating at an
incredibly rapid rate.
Um,
everything is political there.
It's as if the philosophical and the
psychological and the theological don't
exist.
And you know,
increasingly in my interviews I've been
talking about what's been happening at
my lectures on my tour and describing
the fact that the vast majority of the
audience isn't there for political
reasons at all.
They were there because they want to
figure out how to have a responsible and
meaningful life.
And it's as if that story just doesn't
exist.
The,
the,
the framework,
which is basically a political framework
and increasingly a politically correct
framework,
doesn't allow that to exist as a
reality.
And that's why,
well,
I'm much more comfortable lecturing to
the crowds that have been coming to see
me than I am talking to journalists.
It's become,
I have to,
I have been limiting my,
my interactions with journalists,
even though that might not be self
evident yet.
I have been trying to do that,
that the demands have been increasing.
So the proportion of media invitations
that I've responding to has fallen
dramatically,
even though the absolute number hasn't
declined as precipitously.
And the reason for that is that while I
find the,
I find the typical interview very
stressful,
very,
very stressful.
I'm on guard.
And I would say also my attitude isn't
as good as it could be any more because
I've been,
I'm,
because I'm on guard so much,
it's easier for me to get a bit snappy
and an unpleasant and that's bad.
That's bad.
I don't want to do that.
I want to stay calm and detached and try
to,
you know,
tell the truth and be happy that I'm
there regardless of the circumstances.
Um,
the fact that the mainstream media,
let's say is not very receptive,
although sometimes there's exceptions,
not very receptive to the idea that I
could just be going around talking to
people who want to get their life
together is quite saddening.
And I think it's definitely a commentary
on the fundamental corruption of our
media apparatus.
Um,
I think it's better to talk on youtube,
to speak on my podcast to do these
lectures.
And I think it's increasingly better to
do that.
The long form discussions on youtube
though with people like Joe Rogan and
Dave Rubin and,
and so forth,
that works just fine.
So the new media form is emerging and I
think it's going to be a lot more
productive.
Um,
it won't be a scripted,
it'll be much longer forum.
It'll be allow for much more
thoughtfulness.
Um,
and
I'm,
but it's okay.
It's not like the media exposure,
although it's been stressful.
It's not like I'm not grateful for it.
Even people who've put me on the spot
very badly have ended up doing me a
tremendous favor.
But the problem is,
is that because
the problem is I'm becoming too much on
garden and I've noticed,
uh,
developing sense of impatience,
um,
within me and some suspicion and that's
not good.
I don't want to be in situations where
those are my fundamental orientation.
It's it,
it's a,
it's a sign of a certain amount of
internal corruption on my part.
And,
uh,
I want to be in situations where I'm
speaking with people,
speaking honestly to people who are
honestly listening.
That would be,
that's a good situation.
So
would you agree with Cs Lewis?
That if you look for truth,
you may find comfort?
If you look for comfort,
you will find despair.
Oh yes.
That's definitely the case.
It's quite an intelligent phrase because
he says,
if you look for truth,
you may find comfort.
He didn't say you will find comfort.
Yeah.
Well,
sometimes if you look for truth,
you don't find comfort to begin with.
That's for sure.
You find a lot of trouble,
but sometimes you have to go through a
lot of trouble to get to set things
right.
If you look for comfort,
despair,
well,
the reason for that is that you can't
look for comfort in life.
Life isn't about comfort.
Life is a deadly game.
It's a game of life and death.
It's a game of good and evil.
It's everything's on the line.
Your sanity's on the line,
you're
your freedom from pain is on the line.
Your freedom from despair is on the
line,
your family is on the line,
there's no comfort.
Life is an adventure and I think the
greatest adventure that you can possibly
have is one is the one that you find if
you look for the truth
and that's a good place to start.
That's been 90 minutes and uh,
I've been reasonably sharp and with it
for the full 90 minutes.
And so I think I'll bring it to a close.
Just a couple of reminders for those of
you who tuned in late,
if you want to try out the self
authoring program,
I made a code August and that an titles
you to 20% off.
There's a two for one special so you can
give it to a friend as well.
If you want to try to understand myself,
which is a personality test,
it only takes about 15 minutes.
It's quite a bit easier than the self
authoring suite.
Um,
the code for that is also August.
That also gives you 20% off.
Self authoring helps you write about
your past and present and future and you
can do a bad job.
And if you haven't developed a life plan
and you don't know where you are and you
don't know where you're going,
then I would highly recommend trying the
program.
And you're welcome to do a bad job at it
because a bad plan is,
is a lot better than no plan at all.
And understand myself will help you
understand who you are for better or
worse.
And,
and people have responded quite
positively to it.
So I think it's worth the 15 minutes in
the nine 95 that it costs,
um,
discounted 20% now.
So I guess that's about seven 95,
something like that.
So that,
um,
the second Iceland lecturer is going to
come out soon.
I released the first Iceland lecture,
which is part of 12 rules for life.
I have a tour coming out through the
northeastern part of the United States
starting in September and then over to
the UK and northern Europe in September
and October and then Australia and New
Zealand in February.
Um,
I've really enjoyed the tour.
I think it's an amazing opportunity.
It's been extraordinarily heartwarming,
let's say,
to talk to so many people who are trying
to put their lives together.
And if enough people do that,
then they will put their lives together
and that will help put everything else
together.
And so,
uh,
hopefully these q and a's are a smart,
small part of that.
So thank you very much for listening in.
And I'll try to do one in September.
Um,
if I don't,
it's because I'm on the road all the
time,
but I will definitely try to do one in
September.
So thank you for,
to my patrion supporters.
Um,
I mentioned to you guys that I am
working hard on the online university
and have hired three people to work on
that and that we're,
we're about a year ahead of schedule,
I would say,
where I thought I'd be so in three
months were a year ahead of where I
figured I'd be.
We'd be.
So,
um,
thanks again.
Good night.
Ciao.